[Applaudissements]
ali tu as vu qu'on vient d'assister un
drame parce que c'est la fuite des
cerveaux à dubaï
j'espère que tu vas nous remettre du
baume au coeur parce qu'on a pris dans
la gueule retour des frères y aura
d'abord pour maman et justine fraioli
nouvelle émission que c'est vite c'est
les gens fonctionnent disent leur amour
pour maman mais ouais ouais ouais nan ça
c'est pas très bon délire belle comme
sur d'autres délires concours 5 et 24
ans télé voulait qu'il fallait pas rater
la télévision française étrangère ça la
tomate oignon chef le tout très très
très très très vite regardez ces
participez vite on a regardé du catch l
hallucinante cette image vu son arrivée
loupé sur le ring t'es pas sûr que le
catcheur titus o'neill renom injonction
arrive
[Musique]
on est tombé sur le dresseur qui
changent de plus d'émotions moins de
deux secondes avec son aigle chouïa
lunatique à la main ou fait rêver même
ceni euros l'heure pour travailler son
bikini body pour cet été on l'a grillé 7
après avec sa meilleure cox au capital
on est tombé sur le gars qui était mal
réveillé ce matin il est parti est la
voix de sa femme chantal store partant
du boulot ça répit l'elysée une raison
pour laquelle hôtelier aime travailler
avec des agences pour nous important de
ce concept analyse martin de matinée
parti trop vite
retrouvez dans midi en france dans le
public on a vu quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien le père noël à la cool ça y est
elle est passée en mode était le père
noël
la saison c'est la patte saison e et
enfin sur le net on a vu la réaction de
mokhtar quand il a appris qu'il avait un
week-end de trois jours
bientôt le crazy horse commerce et les
chaînes de trois jours c'est à dire on
sera là lundi et on sera là mardi 8 le
sien jusque là en direct et tout un tas
également avec l'oignon sera là aussi on
est là on bosse on est payé on est
devant vous êtes payé pareil
merci pour cette 15e journée foot moi
c'est les relations publiques en 2012
mais calmez vous ça va en plus d'acheter
vos robes chez conforama le confort
avant les clous le clou là c'est pas l
excellent elle ajouté aujourd'hui voilà
hilarant sur un délire de mai claouey
pas en kto est ça la date à laquelle
elle est vénère à tout va bien c'est mon
pas de toi même toit on a des dossiers
calme-toi des cours des seuls trois des
quatre fils était calme on a des
dossiers surtout on sait où tu es ont
elles aussi on connaît à et c'est bon
les deux on les a aussi on connaît vous
avez du côté de nogent sur marne
guinguette
c'est le côté de la bonne ambiance pour
moi j'aime les stars il sauté de veau
donc j'ai regardé top chef spécial
célébrités tout ce que j'aime
rassemblant d'une émission qui
célébrités on pense immédiatement à
danièle evenou forcément elle fait
partie de la bande à dany elle a même
tenté une petite blague mais ça prend
pas on était un peu celle de gens me le
paper regarde ses repas stanick aussi
physique
moi je me suis toujours dit qu'il
fallait tout aille regarde moi c'est
drôle non non ils se ruent vers le chef
michel sarran il s'est aussi posé une
question à laquelle avec ta réponse en
découvrant le pl poule
qu'est ce que c'est que ce dresseuse ça
me fait penser à quelque chose mais je
n'arrive pas à voir quoi je peux le dire
je suis resté dans l'univers cuisine
avec millions sur france 3 cette semaine
le plateau il s'est installé à bourges
c'est un événement pour une ville comme
bonjean plateaux télé au coeur de la
ville donc lundi tout le monde est venu
les voir ça fait plaisir plein de monde
mardi c'est plus calme les gens ont
compris que c'est pas non plus la
croisette et mercredi tout le monde
s'est passé le mourir plus personne ont
versé plus laurent boyer ouais c'est moi
qui suis pas aux abords de toi même
temps la sneakers et moi j'étais
embrassé très fort danièle evenou mais
bien sûr beaucoup merci j'ai regardé des
marseillais fera t on à la papaye
c'était tranquille au bord de la piscine
ils se sont dit iem pourcel jaillir va
visiter cimetière ambiance
anthony en profite pour faire une blague
sur les cimetières vu le temps de
réaction car là à mon avis elle aussi en
jet lag au niveau du captage c'est parti
on comprend les vols
direction le cimetière
[Musique]
j'ai gardé pascal le grand frère aussi
on assiste à un bon moment de communion
entre une mère et son fils yann plus
beau que l'amour d'une famille au final
pour cette jeunesse pour la maman c'est
normal mais parler comme ça le fils de
merci nico rappelons que cette maman
retrouvent le sourire grâce à une photo
qui lui rappelle des vrais bref mais
comme si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bonne couleur
majin j'ai regardé plus belle mariée de
tf1 aussi parce qu'on a tous le droit de
traverser un petit moment de dépression
est une des candidates nous donne les
consignes de sa coiffure pour la
cérémonie
si on n'est pas coiffeur ça paraît
compliqué si on est coiffeur sa part est
aussi compliqué parce que je pourrais y
voir merci tu as une idée sur la
coiffure que tu souhaiterais faire je
préférerais une coiffure qui fasse effet
attaché effet détachés plutôt son côté
ou après derrière ça dépend d'accord
c'est aussi sont mariés ils ont des
maillets chaque soir mais la robe de ma
vie on assiste au plus gros tacle de la
semaine la vendeuse elle essaie de se
placer une vente elle se prend un mur et
toi tu es en couple aussi oui c'est cool
ça fait combien de temps huit mois
je suis entré chez moi petit marais non
je crois pas
nelson monfort rapidement à isabelle ils
ont un petit enfant de ça on l'a vu dans
le 12 13 3 ces cadeaux à l'université de
nanterre que dominique tabac vécu mai 68
et dans météo à la carte pourra trouver
la destination de vacances idéale pour
un des poteaux de l'équipe et si on
partait dans les côtes d'armor visiter
un lieu unique au monde
la vallée des singes et ça tombe bien
qu'ils nous regardent également qu'on
embrasse boston s'il ya quelqu'un qui
paraîtra pas la vérité est venu et bravo
codotussyl aux velléités du monde entier
aussi week end avant de partir en
pologne en allemagne je commençais par
9h52 matin c'est sur france 3 il ya une
des journalistes qu'elle essayait de
faire découvrir le métier de préparateur
de cheval pour les préparer avant les
compets a oppressé bien sa belgique mais
dans le lapsus de l'animatrice à mon
avis elle lui prédis pas un grand avenir
dans ce milieu neurologue et soignante
ben oui on vous voit en train de
préparer le chômage sur scène ils ont
interviewé une dame qui réagit après les
incidents en marge des manifestations à
ça du drame
elle se rattrape tout juste eu le temps
de se mettre à l'abri
un moment donné je voyais cette bande de
nuit
des jeunes dans un jt en pologne ils ont
fait un duplex pour le lancement d'un
tout nouvel avion regarder équipés
d'android très sophistiqués pour
apporter des images jamais vues
auparavant
le décollage a eu lieu en direct mais
l'atterrissage aussi c'est assez rare
l'atterrissage aussi ses galères et dans
un journal allemand on a assisté à la
mise en place d'un immense repas
officiel en direct on a croisé le
serveur qui va avoir beaucoup de temps
libre
ces jours ci
oh là là quelle
la mort
bâtard comment s'inscrire à pôle emploi
le regarde pas mal mais c'est quand même
un gars du nouveau le coup j'ai envie de
ça et des minions un accès un bavarois
ce petit coup d'oeil sur les très bien
c'est mon chouchou vous connaissez mois
après toi toutes chaînes confondues et
il est chaque matin sur scène devrait
apprécier
c'est l'économiste eric de riedmatten
vrai celui qui fait des vannes grave
il est hyper drôle passé en fait il fait
plein de blagues de profs de gestion
sauf que c'est le seul prof de gestion
en plateau donc les microbes ebit
stratosphérique chômeuse bonne ce qui
met des tréteaux et d'étapes donc à
savoir d'envoyer si vous ne respectez
pas les règles si vous vendez d'une
grille vous risquez de vous faire tirer
les clochettes
c'est donc une émission sur idf1 ya
isabelle olivier ont essayé de surf et
ta cagnotte qu'ils organisent à nous y
tenons à l'antenne et il va pas rester
dans les annales de la télé rooney ni
oui ni non
ça commence avec isabelle pendant deux
minutes tu ne réponds jamais oui jamais
non
sympa donc dans les aéroports à voile a
échappé belle sur france 5 pour les ont
soumis un garde forestier il entre en
contact avec un animal très rare
il n'en revient pas lui-même ce très
rare le localiser
aurait pas de rater autre chose j'ai
maté très froid aussi
ah ouais karité the limit forme et slam
notamment aussi le jeu de cyril féraud
alors vous savez si et de ferro il à
l'islam et la crainte d'autres et
notamment la carte autres et alors il
anime tous sur soi et ce qui est bien
c'est que le mercredi du coup slam c'est
plus un jeu c'est une bande annonce
d'une heure pour le prime que c'est
lille qui suit après bien sûr vous êtes
des aventuriers sachez que dans deux
jours et le retour de la carte aux
trésors monde et vous ce soir 21h pour
la carte au trésor
c'est le rayon de la carte au trésor
c'est le retour de la carte au trésor
mercredi jour de cartes au trésor s'est
glissé le château de montségur qu'on
visitera peut-être pour le deuxième
épisode de la carte au trésor
c'est donc dans motus sur france 2 cette
fois aujourd'hui avait un vrai niveau de
fou au niveau des mots proposer que du
niveau sérieux vraiment m'amuser
mrm aux huées se tait à la 8 1 milliards
au 8e folique et elle fait re à lui n'a
qu'élite beac a eu le battoir huppé hâte
en revanche d'autres biden c'est autre
chose saucisse plaisir avant les frais
on s'est amusé à mélanger les répondants
la finale des amours les questions qui
vont pas être les réponses ça veut rien
dire ça nous fait mal ketty teddy
connaît-il top l'animal qui vous fait le
plus peur oui angela merkel votre
dessert préféré
oui et si je le dernier objet que vous
avez acheté dans un vide greniers oui
surtout leur sont l'objet que vous
emmèneriez sur une île d
oui le métro leader que vous aimez
sentir dans la cuisine puis la tarte
d'emplois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pas quitter les vraies réponses à
un prix correct mais ce qui est sympa et
qui va les frères oui j'attendais les
faire y at il des risques homme qui lève
la main genre oui oui ce que vous
connaissez les frères on en arrête des
gens dans la rue et pendant qu'ils nous
répondent rapidement on s'attend pour
moi c'est pas le nom de la rubrique vous
ai déjà vu qu'on fera une interro sur
tpp la regarder des nouveaux épisodes
les a tonné hier on s'en fout j'ai gardé
mon calme toi qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun page s'est fait
grève on attendra c'est tout ça me plaît
pas mais on peut qu'attendre ans on n'a
pas l'autre transports à prendre c'est
tout voilà votre seul en pense quoi
votre soeur elle en pense quoi 6
joutard gens n'aiment pas ça ah ça c'est
toi
elle fait llp paris express c'est vrai
mais massa allez on sent des banques
rosport bonne continuation
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
c'est je trouve qu'ils sont sales et qui
devrait être rénové un peu plus j'ai
appris qu'on changer la couleur des
métros mais un petit peu plus de
nettoyage se ferait pas de mal je pense
et votre frère il en pense quoi
oh [ __ ] c'est cette émission là avec
l'histoire du frère non la démission
c'est ça voilà c'est camille castagne le
latium pas de moi non plus caché près
d'où on à ken non
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
au club parisien
mais je pense qu'en ce moment c'est un
peu problématique à cause des grèves
mais voilà je n'utilise pas tous les
jours et là en plus j'ai entendu qu'il
ya des grèves là pendant quelques jours
un jour bonjour et saint philippe du
roule à pirou les animaux
je pense que c'est pas là il faut aller
par un opéra par an après on pleure nous
avons limité mon accent pas du tout
avant vous avez lamérac ça vous venez de
quel pays des portugais
serbie est servi par là ou pas dans
l'est c'est pas de la merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]